aber wer mal hier kommt crafter dass das
tier finde ich extra halt das ist eine
hantelbank behindert miteinander der den
als am start ich bin am start und dem
spiel minecraft hero auf dem exit mal
gestorben alter alle baron nicht mit dem
tode
ja ich bin noch half er gestorben als
seicento rickens bei dir auch bei mir
ist ehrlich du bist alt ist ist statt
rot ist die stadt des guten wetters muss
dass das nicht stimmt kann es doch gar
nicht regnet also ich habe in der
letzten folge in den letzten folgen war
ich in so vielen gottverdammten festung
und ich habe sie so viele geile sachen
gesammelt
ich sortiere das erst mal ganz kurz in
der zwischenzeit kannst du ja sagen wat
wi denn wir machen möchten sagt ja auch
aber ich kann einfach vergessen regen
die weihnachtszeit ist ein fest der
liebe und ein fest des zusammenkommt und
des miteinanders der nächstenliebe und
da dachten wir uns natürlich was wäre
ein besserer zeitpunkt als einen
friedensvertrag zu schließen zwischen
crafter und dana ja und was war das
machen ja das war
wir wollten so ein bisschen runterkommen
so besinnliche zeit dachten wir uns dies
das anders wir machen so ein bisschen
hackmack hier nicht also keine hackmack
wir machen schöne sache nicht ohne folge
und da wollen wir einen kleinen
friedensvertrag stützen deswegen wir uns
auch gleich treffen möchten und wir
wollen keinen krieg mehr haben
ich find auch creek durfte normaler also
mit somit angreifen und so du bist
einfach café du wirst mich wieder
angreifen nein weil ich wirklich nicht
nicht weihnachten gedanken ich mache
mich grad für coole reinforced diamond
fest ich glaube ganz die leute jetzt
gucken warten gerade auch die bescheren
ach die sind auch so geil wie kann man
ja so zusammen machen also damit sich
menschen ich habe echt richtig geile
sachen gefunden ich habe mir aus alles
ich habe cloud boots gefunden
richtig schöne sachen richtig war aber
auch schon fetten schatz gefunden dann
zwar dass man ganz viele essenzen also
wenn ich zu dir kommen
ich komme einfach mal zu dir oder zu mir
und dann
was du mir vielleicht mit punkt kommst
ja ich kann mir kannst du mir eventuell
existenzen geben in welche hast ich hab
nur eine einzige ich kann dir was gar
nicht du musst mir etwas geben wenn ich
etwas gäbe ja ich geb dir das und als
gegen dafür gebe ich dir doch einfach
was mich zu haben
ich habe sogar zwei ex ist jetzt ein
soap ist hätte ich gerne eine okay gut
was ich kann mir aber auch so wie wofür
brauchst du den stabis ich möchte mir so
eine discokugel braun und ich brauchte
noch einen stopps für die mich mir auch
bauen heißt denn die hat ja nicht
gewünscht so weihnachten jetzt konnte
heißt diese disco kugel in der echse
drin
ich weiß wirklich dreist die heißt weiß
ich nicht starr peace die damit die ganz
schnell ab so behindert zu reden
box die auf small ich zu dir kommt auf
friedensvertrag kratzmann wie viel ich
einfach ich habe etwas bringt die kritik
bauermann hat die crew menze ich sag dir
das ding heißt das heißt dass teure
stars da fehlt mir noch
vielleicht habe ich sogar einen irgend
einer kiste und ich weiß es noch nicht
vielleicht habe ich einen irgendwann
beamten kiste da stimmt alles da was
kann ich ihnen stars machen und kammern
hinstelle leuchtet das wirklich alles
was er kann
ganz einfach sowieso hinsetzen irgendwo
ja natürlich ich habe jetzt so ein omaha
der sind verschiedene farben schießt das
habe ich mir gewünscht
egal wie er aussieht sollten ist
weihnachten schenken nein nur 1 tag ich
mir selbst kräften hefe selbsthilfe ok
muss gucken ob ich eines tages überhaupt
raus natürlich müsse man die sachen
sollte ich habe so viele essenzen alltag
der klink vom format
ich hab es da dass er wo er mich ins da
das wasser bekommt man dann hast du
schlecht wenn man spät so dass sie wie
zurückverwandeln glaube ich ich habe
drei existenz hier
ich frage die viele gesammelt oder wen
ich sterbe horsel machte aber jetzt muss
ich ja langsam auch mal mich daran
setzen ihren klassenstärke zu machen
neue ja ich habe alle sterben nicht
rollen sich spät kommst und wer gar
nicht mehr
ich komme sofort ja gut ich pack die
sachen jetzt erst mal einfach so hier
ein sortieren werde ich das immer noch
nur damit ich die gemeinde meinen ganzen
scheiß rucksack ich erstmal er hat neue
existenzen freunde das ist eine gute
ausbeute finde ich von der leyen sicher
nicht meckern
ich brauche nur einen fall weiter wird
infiniti aufgaben gar in beggendorf
statt blau ach so ich neben einfachen
spiegel mit zu euch dann mache ich mir
da in unseren links drauf ich hab das
mit den schwerinern nicht verstanden
da kann ich den ball bringen ein
weiteres geschenk an sich ist ein
tutorial okay was was du sonst ja er
kann ja mal nicht geben
tschuldigung bitte sagen ich hab's halt
nicht echt bitte bitte bitte lass das
wirklich nicht
du armes stück ich kann den zauberstab
schwenken
schavan habe ich genug weil es keine
zauberstäbe ich habe sie mir noch nicht
greift aber ich könnte auch geschenk
durfte kann man gar keine freude machen
den den das richtig traurig gerade merkt
man richtig montreals weihnachten ist
den nehme ich mit
die kaká ich komme sofort das merke ich
dass wieder direkt neben dem haus steht
ist gerade nein
nicht weihnachten nicht du kannst mir
vertrauen
ok hier sind du dich spiegel drin
ich habe so viel scheiße mein wenta ich
hasse mich dafür warum ist das so viel
scheiße wirklich dass da nicht haben
kokubo lag alter blogger microblogger
anika decker mittlerweile douglas als ob
ehrlich das wirklich gehört auch eine
adäquate ich mag einfach mal die ganzen
unnötige sachen darin die ich gar nicht
brauche und 26
die sortier folge ist wie ich komme
sofort durch werde vor da ich in meinen
rucksack in die kiste auch gut er ist
sofort wieder da ja sie sagen dass
zuletzt die und paketen
ich komme der foto kann schon mal sein
buch verzaubern
doch nicht fertig das geht wieso soll
ich im buch verzaubern
ja für den vertrag müssen was ein
schreiben bekommen keine level du hast
du hast mir meine level nicht
wiedergegeben ich hatte so level
flaschen mussten wir einfach nicht
wiedergegeben höre man kann froh sein
dass die sachen wieder gegeben habe ich
hätte einfach alles behalten können
ich hab übrigens in rift blade und habe
goldene äpfel gefunden und bleib ich hab
auch außenangriff case weggeschmissen
wir euch auch lacke sind
ich habe ja nicht verstanden mehr
funktionieren lederbogen goldene bücher
dann auch gefunden
richtig geil was ich das gefunden haben
was darf gefunden gipfel in der nacht
mit wenig schlaf da macht gewinnt leute
wegdrücken
ich bin besonders stolz was gefunden
richtig viele mexikaner setzen
darauf bin ich stolz okay was richtig
viel also richtig viel hektik ist ein
die viel electric essenzen und durchaus
sehr stolz auf ihn sind die cloud wut
die ich gefunden habe bin ich auch gal
und dann von den sachen die hier drinnen
brauche ich nicht wirbelwind bot sie
sind noch deutlich cooler ich glaube
nicht dass die cola bin doch ich glaube
schon
so wie messi mich sicher so und jetzt
war ich hab wirklich schockiert bin
krass alter man kann diese kisten gar
nicht sortieren hier diese scheiße hier
angeblich kann man die monster unserer
stadt übrigens benutzen
9 aber das können wir nur preis so
häufig nur neun filmen und stege ich hab
nur neun existenzen alter unseres 16
also ich brauch noch 700 ja gut ich
komme zu dir dann macht das so dann mein
spiegel ist immer noch auch hier
fokussiert ich muss durch das portal von
zombie gehende ich kann aber nicht durch
irgendwie ich weiß nicht wie bis dahin
gekommen
zu hause lassen es ist noch nicht
abgeschlossen ich kann natürlich ich
habe ein bisschen angst
da ist nicht auf unserer seite wie ja
der ist nix schlimme ist ach so da ist
nicht eine falle oder sind ja ich bin
ich so wie komme ich jetzt raus ich kann
man nachkommen tische draußen menschen
sogar ohne etwas kaputt zu machen
oha hat sie mal heftigen baum gebaut
alter nein des gewachsen so ich dachte
schon blog beinbruch aber sie bleibt
auch bei dem ja ich finde mein penis
sieht auch gut aus eigentlich das sieht
richtig schön aus bei simon war ich
etwas klauen steht einfach ein schild
bei ihm im haus kurzauftritt symboltier
man sich schnell drehen vertrag machen
ja hast du level
ich habe 46 level
ja und ich habe nämlich noch verzaubert
mit
ich soll einfach ich habe die level du
warst ein friedensvertrag machen du
verschwindest dann ging's fall ja ich
habe auch 1000 naja so hart aus der
lampe wie macht man sich die leg dich
mal deinen speck operation
ich will auch mal kann es auch mal wie
das da sehe ich die reckte der frisch
operation mit dem nichts doch was hast
du gemacht hast das alles darf was weißt
du denn hier
bis kurz langsam jetzt oder nicht kein
brot toll dann bringt er gar nix hier
macht ihr so irgendwann ich gesperrt bin
ich es gab bisschen langsamer
der magix der macht nur normalen schaden
crazy ich würde gerne aber mit meinem
leben metal james ward schlagen und
schauen was passiert wenn mainz so 1
darf ich mal schlagen ja ein hai bisher
passiert wirklich nichts wenn wir
wirklich wahrscheinlich einfach nur weil
ich einmal schlagen mit dem energy and
sword das nicht verzaubert ja ja doch
macht mir hat auch ränder teilt aber das
möchte ich mit was nicht mal verzaubert
was wenn ich dich mit dem boden ab tiefe
nein bitte nicht tue es nicht schrieb
passierte nichts martin falschen
doch dieses schwarze sachen drauf hatte
ich sterbe hier fast gerade lederball
weltfrieden vertrag machen
stifter immer nur den vertrag machen
alter lasst es doch mal an ich habe echt
kein opfer von b.free ich darf mir mal
friedensvertrag gesagt ja aber ich
wollte es noch mal ausprobieren
ja aber ich habe ein bisschen doof weil
ich hab jetzt viereinhalb herzen
hast du jetzt hast du dich mittlerweile
fast ein buch was du im hoch noch nicht
statt es schön bei nacht eure stadt ist
viel schöner als unsere
ja klar wir sind ja auch stadt drop wir
haben mehr als nur einen job combo alter
ihr habt dahin ja auch so ein party
block kriging london
ja es ist nur ein dass unsere
party song hey was ist das denn ist es
doch ein stars sonst achtlos 2 box weiß
das weil wir müssen natürlich auch beide
einen vertrag haben
wieso ist dieser star blog bei dir diese
gitter denn in die höhe
das ist ganz toll meteoriten
abwehrsystem als ob er liebt ja aber ich
kenne mich mit diesen technischen zeugs
nicht zu hause aber auch leute mir so
gesagt bei uns leuchtet das nicht sogar
wie bei euch vielleicht hatte es nicht
aktiviert dann hilft es gar nichts als
er sieht aber richtig geil aus damit das
sieht richtig schön aus eure stadt
gefällt mir was das denn was passiert
ich erklärst du das hier ist ein haus
mit kisten hier drin wählen wir hunde ok
müssten auch bald wählen ja irgendwie na
klar jetzt ist die wahlwerbung direkt
preis entgegen gelaufen kommt rein
was machst du denn da komm ich jetzt
mein schiff vertrag macht ja ich muss
kurz war werbung machen du konzentrierst
dich nicht auf die wichtigen dinge im
leben
so setzt der macht nix noch kein schaden
er macht jetzt mit zwei bücher ja danke
so also du musst zwei bücher machen
wie beschreibt man die irgendwie müssen
die wie hell wie macht man daraus magic
buch braucht man da finde ich noch mehr
druck nehme man braucht nur ein amboss
das kann mir beim wahlzentrum machen
kommen mit da waren wir doch gerade den
fünf minuten noch wenn man da jetzt
durch das schaffen mehr okay hier ist
anders so rein
neben ähnlich nicht stimmt das nur so um
so zu beschreiben wir wollen buck und
väter oder das heißt gott war echt
complicated
wir haben sex sex sex
wir können mehr einfach irgendwelche
töten hast du nicht in welche x6 alter
wir müssen uns jetzt erstmal bei allen
sein schneller
ich habe keine wahl ich hab noch nie
irgendwelche gekillt aber im meer
schwimmen angst immer ich herum oder
eigentlich sind die immer weicher focus
pen die nächste welle ist ein deutscher
im wasser sein können der chip jedoch
den er redet als wäre er ein
fünfjähriges kind
ok jetzt ein ganz ruhiges betrunken
gewesen und friedhof umgebaut
ja da war nicht mehr genug platz ich bin
so häufig gestorben oha leuchtet alles
wie geil aus als bei uns ich war zum
beispiel zum beispiel auch zwei der ganz
fehler gemacht hatten auch alle anderen
scheiße was machen wir jetzt
wir können auch das buch einfach
verzaubert und friedensvertrag nnen ich
bin irgendwo reingefallen bei euch hier
ist das ein blaser brunner von angst
oder schwermetalle
wir nennen es den hochofen das heißt ja
auch hochofen
nein die kann man wir haben kein
verwickelt das jetzt nicht mehr machen
da auch die verzaubernde und denn die
einfach friedensvertrag dann kam halt
nicht sein treiben aber wir können auch
eni schreiben
aber wir können ja das über nicht
verzaubern
dort kann das buch am amboss einfach ein
schon binnen okay stimmt ja dann
schreibt nichts rein aber eigentlich
müssen wieder was rein schreiben
wir sagen aber friedensvertrag dann weiß
jeder was gemeint ist
vertrag von versailles
chancen schöne weihnachtsfans vertrag
oder schon nein da wird wir uns einmal
schlagen mit dem buch in der hand
ok damit wir müssen jetzt rechtsklick
rechtsklick linksklick recht wir können
ja dass irgendwann nochmal wir können
uns ja meine kommentare einen text
schreiben die wieder sehen wir dann da
rein schreiben dann treffen uns
irgendwann mal wieder und voll fühlen
dass sie aber erstmals ein provisorium
nämlich auch weihnachten jetzt schon
bisschen frieden ist auf 31 21 live ab
ok jetzt 1241 siehst du mich näher doch
12 wir haben frieden reden nur frieden
für die welt ja klasse krieg
fragezeichen was ist das was das hier
auf daraus ja müssen eine stadtmauer
bahn schloss auf einem der farm gelände
hafen machen den ok dann macht man halt
machen will kommt oft erreichen
schreiben einfach gut gefährlich kaum
kräfte stützen unterschied meine lieben
freunde folge nichts geschafft aber wir
mal hier konkreter das macht hier für
dich extra alters ist eine hantelbank
trotzdem behindern gebaut damit überall
trainieren kleiner zu besuch bist du ja
schon genug vom angucken des gesichtes
nur so kann ich hab einfach eine
verdammt der hantelbank gebaut man ein
foto von ihm machen so
kopieren will kux studentin kombinieren
wie kork scheiße der sache mit dem buch
machen was das hier ist das eine
leinwand im kino nein dass uns unsere
whitewall reithofer ich weiß was ich
bespreche der taktiken bei hp das ist
unglaublich sagt brauchen da wir haben
sogar die hantelbank 100 kilo hantel
bank ich glaub's nicht mehr von der hand
was ist das das ist für solche seien
einfach glaube ich jetzt einfach dabei
ein schönes ich glaube dass die folge
statt nicht im raum und deswegen möchten
jetzt auch die folge werden weil die
folge ist mein ganzer stab geht kaputt
wenn ich so häufig hoch fliegen muss
hier
hallo laboriert sich erfunden haben
meine freunde nicht gefallen dann könnte
eine bewertung lassen sonst würd ich
sagen
in der nächsten folge kannst du uns ja
mal besuchen kommen ok trinken
sexistisch am morgen geht es weiter
ich wünsche euch frohe weihnachten wenn
solch kleiner lassen da und dann mach's
gut sagt ja bis morgen